[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a hindi language
biographical sports drama film called
dangal
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the protagonist of the film is a former
indian wrestler named mahavir singh
fogad long ago he left wrestling because
of financial difficulties and is
currently stuck in a government office
job one afternoon mahavir is in the
office watching the 1988 seoul olympics
the former state level wrestling
champion harkinder also works alongside
him the two get into a slight argument
and challenge each other to a match of
dango being a professional wrestler and
double the size of mojaver harkender is
confident but when the fight starts
mojaver slams harkinder to the ground in
no time the results are the same in the
following two rounds as well after the
match mojave asks harkinder to lighten
up because he didn't lose to just a
normal man but to a national level
wrestling champion mojave quit wrestling
years ago but his dream to win a gold
medal for his country hasn't died yet
hence he wishes to train his future son
from an early age when he and his wife
daya are expecting a baby mojave
frequently stares at the medals and
pictures of his achievements on the wall
he dreams that one day his son's medals
will replace his own but when daya gives
birth to their first child she turns out
to be a girl gita the news is
bittersweet for the father but he still
has hope the villagers give him unwanted
advice on how to conceive a son some say
to try on sunday mornings while others
advise them to fast on specific days a
year after trying every method the
result is the same and the couple is
blessed with their second daughter
babita declaring that the third time's
the charm mojave starts trying for a boy
again however after they give birth to
two more girls the couple is done having
children for a lifetime mahavir finally
accepts defeat and takes down the
pictures from the wall years pass and
gita and babita have turned into
teenagers they are like any other girls
in the town but they are very scared of
their strict father one evening mojave
returns home to see his neighbors in
front of his house they complain about
gita and babita beating up their sons
the two seemingly strong guys have
turned blue because of the girls instead
of asking the daughters what went wrong
mojave urges them to show him how they
managed to beat the guys on seeing that
the girls are naturally talented in
wrestling he registers that they're just
as good as a son he curses himself for
wanting a boy while his daughters were
right in front of him all along girls if
your fathers are disappointed that you
weren't boys just kick someone's ass at
night mojave tells daya that he wants
his girls to wrestle in the conservative
society they live in girls doing
anything other than household work is
seen as outrageous daya is horrified at
the idea scared of facing society's
criticism but mojave presses her to let
them train for at least a year if they
do not show improvement by then he
promises to let them do whatever they
want the following morning he wakes gita
and bobita at five in the morning as
they cautiously walk outside they are
surprised by their favorite street
vendor who sells their favorite treat
gol gappas the girls are confused but
they devour the treat to their fullest
when they are done mojave bans them from
eating anything oily or spicy from now
onwards they have to follow a strict
diet and train every day like a true
wrestler the girls are too intimidated
to say no to their father they run
several miles that day and return home
with sore muscles since their clothes do
not allow them to run faster they are
made to wear their cousin omkar's shorts
their exposed legs are scandalous for
the reserved neighbors they call mojave
a psychopath for making his girls act
like men but mojave couldn't care less
about their comments on certain days the
girls can hardly stand up straight still
mojave pushes them to their limits and
beyond after getting them in shape it is
time for him to teach them the basics of
wrestling the head of the local
wrestling arena doesn't allow girls to
play in his ring which halts the
training for a while then a determined
mojaver makes a ring on his own in the
middle of the fields a few days later he
registers that the girls need to fight
with men to become stronger than them
the only guy who is eligible to do so is
his nephew omkar when he first gets into
the ring with them he defeats them in
less than a minute but over time failure
only helps the girls keep track of how
far they have improved even though the
fogar family is vegetarian when mojave
notices that the girls need more protein
he fights daiya to allow them to eat
meat mojaver even convinces the butcher
to sell them the meat at a lower price
in turn he promises that the girls will
promote his shop when they become famous
throughout all this he never asks his
daughters what they actually want
eventually gita and babita get tired of
following his orders they complain that
the training is affecting their studies
and their hair according to mojave their
studies should be compromised but
something should be done about the hair
the sisters are happy that they were
able to convince him but it doesn't last
long it turns out that mojave wants to
cut their hair short to solve the
problem it is the saddest day for the
girls as they beg him otherwise but he
doesn't listen people talk about them
even more now that they look exactly
like guys having enough of their father
gita and babita skip practice one day to
go to a wedding as they dance at the
party mojave crashes it and slaps omkar
for being a bad influence on the girls
later that day the sisters omkar and the
bride are together in a room gita and
babita complain about their father
wishing that they were never born they
are shut down by the 14 year old bride
who is forcefully being married off by
her father she compares her parents to
gitas and asks them who they like better
in a society where daughters are
considered a burden mojave is training
them to do something great in their
lives which the bride envies the comment
makes the sisters realize that even
though their father is training them
ruthlessly in the end he is doing it for
them the next day mojave wakes up to see
the girls have already started to train
they train the best they can and
eventually defeat omkar in search of
stronger opponents the father takes them
to a local wrestling competition but
since the participants of the
competition are only guys the organizers
think it is a sin to let girls fight
them to convince them mojave states that
a fight between two genders will surely
attract audiences on the day of the
match a large crowd of people comes to
see gita she is made to choose an
opponent between three boys when she
chooses the strongest one the crowd
gasps knowing that she will never win
the boy also feels the same but is
proven wrong when gita slams him to the
ground in no time people start rooting
for her by the end of the match and are
disappointed when the guy wins still the
crowd respects her for putting up a
tough competition gita is eager for the
next match unable to sleep for two days
because she couldn't win the last one
the girls take part in several wrestling
matches after that gita goes against men
who are stronger than her and is able to
take everyone down their popularity
starts increasing and the meat shop uses
them as sponsors as promised a part of
mojave's dream comes true when his
daughter's medals are displayed on the
wall that once used to hold his
achievements when gita is old enough she
is ready to participate in the national
level wrestling competition since she
had been playing local dengall till now
mojaver has to train her extra carefully
for the nationals he leaves his office
job and starts farming so he can invest
more time in her he also creates a
wrestling mat out of sleeping mats to
teach her the rules of the sport after
training for months the day of the sub
junior finals arrives since gita is used
to fighting with men double her size she
easily defeats all of her opponents and
wins a gold medal cut to a few years
later gita wins the senior national
level championship which is the biggest
national level wrestling tournament this
gives her a pass to compete
internationally the people who made fun
of mojave now praise his long-term
thinking for the international level
training gita is made to move into a
government-run training center in
patiala mojave is worried that a new
coach named pramad won't recognize her
strengths and weaknesses when he tries
talking to the coach pramod gets angry
and asks him to go away he is an
egocentric man who thinks his methods
are absolute his attitude makes mojave
more worried for his daughter but he has
no choice but to return home pramod
begins the training by asking the girls
to forget all the wrong diet plans and
techniques they have learned up until
now starting the next day he teaches the
girls his self-proclaimed better
techniques that completely change gita's
way of approaching a fight her biggest
strength is her ability to attack but he
asks her to play defensively just
because he thinks it is good for her the
new environment causes gita to divert
from wrestling she starts growing her
hair talking to boys waking up a late
eating anything she wants and so on at
the same time babita also gets old
enough for the national level
championship she follows her father's
direction and trains hard like gita used
to one day gita returns home with gifts
for all of her sisters the length of her
hair and her attitude has changed a lot
in just a few months she subtly
disrespects her father thinking that she
is better than him and forgetting
everything he has done for her later
that day the sisters are training when
gita boasts about the new techniques she
is being taught by her new coach mojave
challenges her to prove that his
old-fashioned technique is wrong the
father and daughter fight against each
other in a very hard to watch match
mojave gives her tough competition but
loses since he is old and weak the next
morning gita returns to the city without
talking to him in the following scene
she flies to sydney for her first world
championship it is the most important
match of her life something she has
dreamed of since childhood however she
does the worst she has ever performed in
her career and loses at the same time
babita wins the national level
championship and has to join the
training academy after her sister she
goes in with the mindset that she will
remember her father's teachings before
the coaches she is also shocked to see
that gita isn't bothered that she lost
the last match she used to lose sleep
because of a single defeat which shows
just how much she has changed a month
later gita has yet another international
match which she loses for the second
time she gets the same result in the
following five matches and doesn't score
a single international win pramod tells
her that she is not made for the
international competitions refusing to
admit that his training did her no good
when at her lowest the only person gita
can think of is her father she calls him
in tears apologizing for everything
mojave cannot help but cry himself in
six months she is going to take part in
the 19th commonwealth match where the
top players of the world are competing
in order to train her for it mojave
decides to come to patiala he and omkar
rent two rooms close to the training
center the girls secretly come to them
in the morning and train for two hours
before their actual training starts they
do good for a few weeks but pramod
eventually realizes what is going on the
head of the sports board is told about
mojave's plan mojave saves the girls
from being disqualified by promising to
leave them alone keeping his promise he
helps gita on the phone by analyzing the
recordings of every match she has lost
and telling her what she did wrong
eventually she wins the trials for the
commonwealth match pramod is furious
when she gives mojave the credit for the
win when the actual championship starts
gita doesn't do well in the first two
rounds of the first match pramod asks
her to focus on defending but mojave
yells at her to attack rather than
defend using her father's advice she
scores several points and wins the round
at six for three in the semifinals she
fights against the ruthless nigerian
wrestler naomi like the previous match
gita thinks of her father's advice and
wins several points but the match ends
in a draw in the additional round she
does the unthinkable by getting free of
naomi's grip and winning the match this
lands her a ticket to the finale at the
after match press conference gita
reveals the change in her game is all
because of mojaver an angered pramod
makes it his mission to get the credit
for the final win the final match is
against angelina a wrestler who has
defeated gita twice before gita is
nervous but mojave motivates her saying
that she is not just fighting angelina
but everyone who thinks women shouldn't
be let out of the kitchen on the day of
the finals everyone excitedly enters the
arena pramod makes a man take mojave to
a storeroom and lock him inside the
match begins without his presence much
to gita's dismay gita immediately takes
a three-point lead and wins the first
round she does well in the second round
as well but angelina changes the game
with a counter-attack in the last round
the game slips from geeta's hands she
trails by four points with only nine
seconds left on the clock then she
recalls a special five-pointer technique
mojave taught her and uses it to win the
match in the last second she finally
becomes the victor and the first indian
female wrestler to win gold in an
international match although it is a
huge achievement her father's absence
makes it less special for gita when she
is awarded the indian national anthem
plays which alerts mojaver right then a
janitor opens the door and lets him out
he embraces his daughters in a hug proud
of them for coming so far the reporters
also ignore premod entirely and focus on
the father and daughters then we see the
pictures of real-life fogot sisters who
are to this date contributing to women's
rights and sports in india subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching